anti-racism as currently configured has
gone a long way from what used to be
considered intelligent
and sincere civil rights activism today
it's a religion and i don't mean that as
a rhetorical faint
i mean that it actually is what any
naive anthropologist would recognize
as a faith if advocates of wokeness
critical race theory and anti-racism
seem to be acting like religious zealots
who must crush
all heretics that's because they are
argued columbia university linguist john
mcwerger at a 2018 debate
at the soho forum for example the idea
that the responsible white person is
supposed to attest to their white
privilege and realize that it can never
go away and feel eternally guilty about
it
that's original sin right there
mcwhorter first explored this idea of
anti-racism as a flawed new religion
in a 2015 essay in the daily beast he's
expanding the concept into a book
tentatively titled the elect due out in
2022
that he's serializing on sub stack it
lays out his argument
about the misguided religious fervor
undergirding the anti-racist movement
championed by people such as robin
deangelo ibram x kendi
and tana haysee coats meanwhile
mcwhorter's latest volume to hit store
shelves
is nine nasty words a study of how curse
words such as
[ __ ] and the n-word became commonplace
unsayable
or something in between reason talked
with mcwhorter about the shifting status
of curse words
and accusations of systemic racism in
contemporary america
thank you for talking to reason thank
you for having me uh let's start with a
um simple question what's the elevator
pitch
for nine nasty words and i guess we're
assuming
it's an elevator that just has two
people in it um the elevator pitch for
nine nasty words is not
why do we curse the book isn't about
that because if you think about it
that's worth about three pages we know
why we curse what it's about
is the words that we use in order to be
profane
and how they got that way how they
change over time
and where profanity might be going
that's what the elevator pitch is
that is we need a roadmap for profanity
so we're always a couple of heads
uh steps ahead of it um so you know can
i ask you
uh because it gave me immense pleasure
you know the opening anecdote is about
how babe ruth's father
wrote in a court document that he had
[ __ ] mrs ruth and she had asked for it
which as a baseball fan and as an irish
american i was like wow this is
kind of an important part of history i
did not learn in catholic school
um but could you recite george carlin's
seven words you can never say on tv
well um a good while ago um mr garland
told us that there's seven words that
you can't say and i can read them off
here
they were [ __ ] piss [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] and tits and what's
interesting about that list is that it's
actually a little bit archaic
now so for example right there's only
one word on there
that is conceivably still unsaleable on
tv or anywhere else yeah
and as opposed to have you ever called
anybody a [ __ ]
for example i'm 55 i don't think i have
ever used that word
well you've got that to look forward to
you know that's what the golden years
are for joe
and you know tits you know it's not the
word that you know you're going to pop
out at the dinner table usually but his
sense of what these words
are is different than what ours would be
and part of what nine nasty words is
about
is how our sense of what profanity is
has changed over time yeah and of course
he was also talking about um
you know you can't say on tv or radio
right because it was
those were government regulated
broadcast tv broadcast network were
regulated
uh you know a place where you know the
government got had to say about it but
it is
fascinating so you know can you talk a
little bit about how
certainly [ __ ] uh [ __ ]
variations on that have become
ubiquitous to a point where
we're two public intellectuals it would
have been a big deal i mean norman
mallor
you know didn't even know how to spell
the word [ __ ] it is novel
naked and the dead it's [ __ ] but so how
did [ __ ] become
okay to say in all sorts of
circumstances well it's part of
something larger which is
that it used to be that profanity as in
the grand old four-letter words
were about religion and about
sex and excretion in the body and so
damn and hell are considered or were
considered profane i mean frankly it's
at the point where
they barely figure as profanity in the
book because they're just not that
potent anymore
but those were about religion then you
have various words
the [ __ ] [ __ ] etc which came to be
considered
particularly nasty especially in about
the 1400s
that some of it has to do with the
reformation believe it or not
and the idea that you're not supposed to
refer to matters of the body
openly in that way now what's happened
with [ __ ]
is that while as recently as say
well i don't know how recent it is but
100 years ago maxwell perkins the famous
editor
would not say [ __ ] he would only write
it down on his desk calendar and show it
to you and this is somebody who's
publishing people like hemingway who
said it
in real life all the time but he really
had to become famous before he could
even use it
in print at all and so the um
the [ __ ] becomes something different
because
what we have today is a completely
different set
of curses although we don't call them
that over about the past 50 years what's
become profane to us what our society is
hung up on
is slurs against groups and so what
was [ __ ] to maxwell perkins
today to us is words like the n-word as
even i sitting here with my black self
and inclined to euphemize it as because
of the way the word's been treated
or the word that refers to gay men that
begins with f
or that horrible word that begins with c
four letters that refers to women
those are our profanity which means that
[ __ ] now
is not what an anthropologist would
recognize as profane
[ __ ] is just salty so what does it um
you know is it is it a sign of social
progress and this may be
beyond your purview but is it a sign of
social
progress uh that you know we now do not
allow the n word or the
c word or the f word to be rooted about
an everyday conversation
i definitely think so i mean it will
show that i'm an atheist and therefore
maybe have a certain bias that i think
that
it's progress that we no longer take
words like damn and hell so seriously
i will say with more confidence that i
think it's progress that we're not so
uptight talking about the body and we're
at the point now where
the words that we really don't want our
children to hear
and we might be happy if our children
never even use as adults
are slurs against groups now one can
fetishize to a point
i feel it's gotten to that point with
the n-word nevertheless the basic
impulse which is that
the worst thing that you can say is a
slur against a group
that's evidence of social moral and even
intellectual
progress i think it's it's a mark of
sophistication that we're now
more worried about the n-word than about
say
[ __ ] we've matured um you know one of
the most
uh the book nine nasty words is an
incredible kind of
um sortie a you know a a
i don't well maybe not a uh military
mission but it's it's
an overflight of you know of the past 50
years worth of pop culture
and you you point out how in shows that
were not just
you know in common circulation but we're
in the top 10
you know norman lear shows uh like the
jeffersons the spinoff of all in the
family
has a huge number of moments where
wheezy or george jefferson are actually
invoking the n-word
what what's going on where you know and
and i don't know that the jeffersons was
about a black family you know that
famously moves out of queens next to
working-class archie bunker
to a uh what is it a deluxe apartment a
deluxe apartment in the sky
yeah even though they couldn't quite
make it to the upper east side i guess
but
um but you know what was going on that
that was seen as progressive really that
people were
willing to do real talking in that kind
of context and now
you know i i after reading the book i
went and searched on youtube half
expecting these to be blocked because of
you know the n-word but they're not
they're out there what do we do with
that is that
you know is is there anything to do with
that other than kind of be
um well actually what's interesting
is that the norman leer sitcoms were
celebrated for having
real language in many ways and they were
actually depicting the way people
really talk and it's funny that that
happened then in the 70s
and today we are so much more
euphemistic that shows
how very much the culture has changed in
terms of what it's hung up on
no longer excretion but slurs and so
what you're referring to
it's funny i've been watching my way
through the jeffersons which is like 250
of those damn things yeah
watching my way through it because of
the pen are you do you like lionel one
or lionel two um you know lionel well
he's still alive so i should be careful
mike evans was a really good actor i
mean he did a great job with that
character
lionel two is a stage actor and i find
that
his his expressions are too large i
don't believe him as the jefferson's
child
and i know we're not supposed to be
talking about this but with berlinda
tolbert
as jenny it's interesting mike evans and
berlinda tolbert
really worked well together you wish
they had done a production of raisin in
the sun
whereas with with damon evans she starts
popping her eyes and rolling around too
it's he was not as good as the other one
but i've been watching my way through
the whole thing and what's interesting
is that
not only does george use the n-word
occasionally the way black people use it
and not always to mean buddy sometimes
he he means the bad kind of black person
but there's one scene where tom willis
says and i am going to say what he says
george calls him a hockey and he says
well george what if i called you [ __ ]
and it's fine i remember seeing that
episode when i was about 13
he's referring to it it's not it's not a
big deal
today you wouldn't show a white actor
doing that on the equivalent show
or if you did it would be announced six
weeks ahead and there'd be all of these
op-eds about it in the action
it would be like showing the prophet
muhammad in an episode of south park
right it would it would be and that show
yeah that shows where where it's gotten
to because yeah the jeffersons could be
honest
today we can't and that's because the
n-word is our profanity it is our taboo
today
is that a problem per se or is that
simply an indication of um
you know of a different set of um
cultural mores
that actually reflect the fact you know
because i'm also thinking there's a
jefferson's episode and
i apologize to my audience which i think
has come to accept
or expect this type of thing but there
is an episode of the jeffersons where an
old
navy buddy of george who he hasn't seen
in decades
shows up and is transgender um
and you know so on on the one hand the
jeffersons may be trafficking in real
talk about racial dimensions
but then this is and almost every 70s
and early 80s sitcom had an episode
where a transgender person shows up and
hilarity ensues
um is it you know is it a sign that
social progress is happening but it's
always uneven
is it actually not progress to when we
can no longer talk about those things
that actually are you know i mean when
things become unsavable
i think that um we
have gone further than i would prefer
on the n word in particular oddly i
think that society had reached its
maximal sophistication about the n word
in roughly the 90s i was doing media
interviews in the 90s or
actually i was doing one media interview
in the 90s where i remember it was me
somebody white and a white interviewer
and we were talking about what i now
call the n word
and we were openly saying the actual
word with taste
you know not over and over again but the
idea was that of course we're gonna
be able to say the word in order to
explain what we're talking about
that was considered perfectly ordinary i
still have it on cassette
and i don't think that was backwards
something started happening right around
then
where we have this new idea that you're
just not supposed to utter that sequence
of sounds at all
and if you do you get in really really
big trouble
i personally feel
that that depicts black people such as
myself as more delicate
than we are it's at the point where
sometimes i'm a little embarrassed
that we're policing the word that
strongly because the implication is that
if anybody says [ __ ] in any way
it's gonna hurt me and remind me that my
great-great-grandfather was a slave and
about jim crow and about redlining
i feel a bit infantilized by that
however i didn't feel infantilized by
the word being prescribed
as a word that you ever hurl at anybody
my sense is that there's a difference
between
using the word and referring to it and
there's some people who
insist that if we keep on allowing
people to refer to the word
then there's this slippery slope and
pretty soon everybody will just start
hurling it as an epithet again
i'm not sure what model of social
development that expectation
is based on slippery slope can be
misused and i think that
a lot of people are being i'd have to
say
studiously paranoid about that it's
one way that i wish we could go back to
1995 and there aren't many
but it's one and you're right about
those episodes you're reminding me of
that
that trans theme in 70s sitcoms where
they would start out serious as the
jeffersons
pretty much does then the second act has
some guy walking on in drag and
everybody's laughing and they never
bring it back to the serious part
that was a backwards aspect of things
but interestingly jefferson's was ahead
on the n-word how do your students feel
i mean you you have been a
college professor now for what 20 25
years
yeah yeah i'm sorry i i'm sorry to be i
realize that makes you feel
old but you know at least you don't look
old um
but how how do students respond to this
kind of stuff i was talking with
a friend of mine who is younger than me
and um
we were talking about huckleberry finn
uh the adventures of huckleberry finn
and what was
kind of interesting to me and and you
know i i have a background in literary
studies but i don't think
any single work is indispensable i hate
when people are like oh how dare you get
rid of this work
and put in this other work or anything
but she said that her
memories of huckleberry finn of the
adventures of huckleberry finn was that
it's that book with the n-word in it
and it seems to me like something has
gone you know something has gone wrong
when that's the recollection of people
who still read the book in high school
in college and that's kind of
what you remember about it and it
reminds me of course that
the classics you know you never want to
teach the classics in high school or
college because then they become
the enemy and nobody really wants to
embrace them but
how are your students dealing with this
or how have they changed over time
are they leading the charge to say hey i
don't want to hear that word
or are they following something that is
being pushed on them by
elites you know it's funny nick i don't
know
that i've ever come across
a reason to use it or not
use it i don't happen to have taught
huckleberry finn
i teach about language and i can say
that
i curse like a pirate in front of my
students i know i tell them
in some of the early classes i'm sorry
but you know i don't censor myself
and if anything they think it's funny
and then they start cursing to when they
talk and i think it's great
i have had parents visit classes and i
said you have to tell your father that
i'm crazy and that he has to expect that
we're going to talk the way you say that
i am a crazy [ __ ] and that comes
out of this mouth
you know yeah i actually say
but not the slurs obviously i would
never do that and i
think you know 20 years ago i would have
said [ __ ] in front of a classroom
today i would never dream of it and i do
think today's students would have a
different feeling about it
than the ones before even back before i
would have only used it in reference
i probably did but today i would censor
myself because
sensibilities have changed so much but
in general
when i talk about profanity which
sometimes i have to for my linguistics
classes
i say i'm going to say this word one
time
and i'm not going to say it anymore but
i want to make sure you know and i'll
say something like the word is [ __ ]
and then we'll talk about it and it has
an interesting evolution i'll say it
that one time
and i figure i should be allowed to do
that um
i would do that with the n-word if i had
to
i think and as a matter of fact i once
did
and a kind of a jocular white guy said
see you or
you just get to do that because you're
black and i said yeah you're right i can
get away with it and
you're awesome professor yeah it's like
i read you know this
do you feel like these kinds of
linguistic prescriptions because
you hear this a lot mostly from people
on the right and that kind of question
of like
white people in particular being like oh
you know we're supposed to be the land
of the free but i'm not
at liberty to use the n word or the c
word or the f
the other f word etc do these
proscriptions
on certain types of words do they get in
the way of actual learning and
discussion
no i don't think so i think that the
prescriptions
can be a nuisance if over
over prescribed for various reasons i
don't think that
we're losing any knowledge by having it
that we have to say the n
word instead of the actual word where
the problem does come in though
is that the new strain because there's a
certain kind of person who
feels a certain comfort in being
offended i hate to say that but it's
true
is that you're not even supposed to say
negro i know of three anecdotes of
professors being brought up before the
gods
for saying negro as it was written in
some now aging texts
out of an idea that that too is a slur
because
some black people would rather not hear
it that takes it too far
for me but in general the idea that
there are words that one does not use
and that these are words that are used
to injure people
the idea that we don't do that is great
you look at an old movie where people
can do that sort of thing so easily you
think about what the past is like
it's good that we're we're beyond that
but i do think that
there's an extent to which we end up
dealing with a kind of performed
delicacy
that i don't particularly enjoy being
assumed to be a part of
but as you know that's just me and most
black people in my position
don't feel that way who am i to impose
but that's how i feel
do you think uh you know going back to
that george carlin
uh you know set of words the seven words
the c word is the one word
uh you know that is arguably is still
unstable and almost and certainly in
pleasant company and things like that
you know in england uh or the british
isles the c word is
used by everybody all the time kind of
as a stutter word and things like that
um is that an indication perhaps that
women
or that female equality has not gotten
as far
that um you know or that that we still
might hear that
uh more than we seem to hear the other f
word or the n word well you never know
just which pathway a word might be taken
down in terms of what it's going to come
to mean
in terms of what its sociological
associations are going to be and that c
word that you're talking about
has had a different pathway
over there as opposed to here where
c-u-n-t can practically mean
buddy it's tossed it's odd for us to
hear it there whereas here
what has happened to that word is very
much a sign of
changing attitudes towards women and i
think that is a good thing i mean that
word is so poisonous that for the
audiobook
of um nine nasty words i had to adjust a
bit
you know especially because i'm black i
could say [ __ ] a certain amount
and i figured okay there you go i could
not say
c-u-n-t over and over again i thought if
i were a woman listening to a male voice
saying that over and over would just
be noxious and so i pulled back on it as
much
as i could and i think that's a good
thing however i don't think it means
that
sexism is more rife in england and
australia there's a there's a chance
element
to these things and it's just that [ __ ]
hasn't gone along for the ride but
that's just partly
that they have a slightly different take
on
words that refer to sex and so for
example talk about
sitcom trash from the 70s they had their
are you being served where they're in a
department store and
the middle aged slightly pretentious mrs
slocum is always saying
well getting up this early wreaks havoc
on my [ __ ]
and the audience goes crazy and then she
has to say something that makes it clear
that she's talking about her cat
that joke would never have gone in the
united states at the time even with
norman lear sitcoms being so
honest nobody could have made a [ __ ]
joke on maude that would not have gone
by
all you get are the occasional um mostly
urban legends that this uh that kind of
exchange happens with
uh alternatively joshua gabor eva gabor
one of the gabor sisters and johnny
carson
or walsh the the joke being you know uh
the actress shows up on the couch with a
cat on her lap and she says do you want
to pet my [ __ ]
and johnny carson says something along
the lines of well you know if you move
your cat i'd be happy to
and i don't know if they're true or not
but this is no there's that's a whole
great sub-genre of urban legends which
have to do with
talk shows and game shows again from the
70s a
strange and wonderful decade if only
because i was young at it so
because we were young um
you know what is the um you know
part of all of your work really takes uh
place against the backdrop of
immense social progress in your lifetime
in your parents lifetime certainly going
back to your grandparents
um why does it seem so difficult for
people and this is this is by way of
intro into your
other book project that you're working
out on sub stack it's it's a fantastic
read
um but um you know why does it seem so
hard for people to accept
that there is progress not the progress
is absolute or complete but you know the
idea that
you know we're in a better place than we
were in 1970 on
you know i'll say every level i mean
like unless you're george wallace
uh you know it's you know it or norman
mailer both of whom
are dead uh but you know like we're
we're doing better as a society
but that seems never to be able to be
admitted um
you know in in these kinds of
discussions it's the funniest thing
because yeah i grew up
very aware of what life had been like
for black people before i was born which
was 1965 which is kind of emblematic you
know i'm born the year that the voting
rights act has passed
and my parents raised me with an
awareness of the way it used to be
by the early 90s when i'm in my my 20s
my sense of the trajectory was that i
had been lucky enough to live on the
other side of something really seismic
and that things were much much better
and always getting better and i knew
there was
what was being called an underclass at
the time but i thought
things are infinitely better it was a
victory
black people should be proud and i
gradually learned in the 90s that that
is not the way most especially educated
black people felt
and that i was considered peculiar and
even irritating
by many black people and some white
people
by thinking that things were so much
better
than they used to be i was supposed to
think that things only changed in terms
of people's manners
and i just i couldn't i couldn't accept
that there's a part of me that should
have been a lawyer
and the reason you and i are talking
about this subject at all is that i just
couldn't let
let it go i thought these people are not
crazy it's not that they're crazy
it's not that they're manipulative it's
not that they're not intelligent
and yet they're seeing a whole different
world than i than i do
and i think what it comes down to is
this weird cocktail
it's that white people really
educated white people especially really
enjoy the idea of showing that they're
not racists
that's actually a victory in itself i
mean think about how archie bunker would
have felt
about this sort of thing but the 70s in
particular were when the idea was not
only that you get rid of segregation
but that you're not supposed to be
prejudiced as people used to say you're
not supposed to be a bigot
and it worked and i think many white
people are very proud of themselves for
that and i think that it's slowly
transmogrified
into a kind of replacement for
protestantism as it eclipses
where your grace is that you are not a
racist
so you have white people who are ready
to demonstrate this at the same time
as you have black people who after
the civil rights revolution are still
haunted by insecurity because of how
black america was treated for almost 400
years
and if you are a human being seeking a
sense of purpose
and security and well-being and comfort
you might choose the victimization
complex
any human being can do this but if
you're a black person
a particular way to do it is to
exaggerate about racism
and to found your sense of significance
on being a victim
of something now referred to abstractly
as systemic racism etc
and so there are many black people who
enjoy
the condescension that i think comes
from a lot of whites
in treating us as these delicate
creatures and so it becomes a kind of
dance shelby steele wrote about this
better than i can ever say it way back
in the early 90s i read him at that time
and i thought
this guy gets it and he clearly isn't
crazy
either and so that's what it is and so
we're not allowed to admit
how much better things have gotten
there's a certain kind of person and you
know
they are of all colors where if you
point to the good news
they don't want to accept it it's
unpleasant for them to hear how
much better things have gone and they're
they're thinking that their job as moral
actors
is to find evidence to go against it and
that's a weird thing i think that's
probably
unprecedented in human history for a
group of people to not
want to admit that things are better we
live in strange times but that's what
happened in the late 20th century in the
united states
you know that uh the invocation of
religion or religious impulse to some of
this
informs your controlling metaphor of the
the book project on
on substance the elect can you uh for
those of us who are not uh versed in
protestant theology
or calvinism i guess could you talk a
little bit about what the elect means
and why you are
choosing that term to talk about people
who are kind of super woke
super politically correct and um you
know
uh reticent to acknowledge any kind of
progress
yeah the elect and i get that term from
joseph bottom it's not it's not mine
the elect is my term for not just woke
people you know i might surprise some
people lately but i consider myself
pretty woke
it's woke people who are mean it's the
nasty
woke people it's the nastiness that
we've seen especially since
last summer during our so-called racial
reckoning and
what i mean by the elect is they're
people who seem to think of their
purpose
as being to demonstrate that they're not
racist
and to police the rest of us for racism
and to defenestrate and shun
people who they deem to be not
anti-racist
enough and so their idea is that they're
doing something that's maximally good
for humankind the idea is that
to battle power differentials and
especially ones about race
is the paramount goal of the concerned
human being
everything is supposed to be centered on
that and
this is important all people won't
understand it but this is so important
that it's okay
to hurt people and it's okay to do
things that you wouldn't urge your own
children to do
in the name of this larger good and so
although the people don't think about it
all of this is very
very cultural revolution very stalin
it's
frankly metaphorically it's hitler in
many ways but
as with all of those people the elect
today the woke people who are okay with
being mean in the name of wokeness
they think of themselves as having come
to the ultimate answer
and the parallels with religion
especially evangelical religion are
almost
uncanny especially given that most of
these people kind of look at scants
at christianity in its more extreme
forms but
white privilege is original sin the idea
is that if you're white you're
privileged and that will never change
even if you're poor no matter what you
do
that's original sin the idea that we're
waiting for america to come to terms
with racism
that has no meaning what what are the
terms what what would that be
you say it and you nod in the same way
as if somebody goes like this and
puts does that circular you nod because
somehow that means yes
well come to terms with race that
doesn't mean
anything what it is is it's the rapture
it's that business of the end of days
and
judgment day the reason that if a person
says something that isn't sufficiently
anti-racist they have to be chased out
of the room
or their job is because it's about
heresy
the idea is we can't even stand to have
andrew sullivan
in our midst in a zoom call you know
andrew sullivan has to resign
and remember the idea was that they
didn't want him around
when nobody was around each other
because it was in the middle of the
pandemic that's because they think of
him they thought of him at new york
magazine as a heretic they wouldn't use
those words
the parallels just go on and on and so
you have a clergy
you have writers who are looked to
to say things over and over again many
of which are very hard to square with
reality
but frankly people like ta-nehisi coates
and now robin d'angelo and
ibram ex-candy they are priests
of this religion they don't think of
themselves that way they're certainly
not
saying it but the way their writings are
received
is not as informational tracks
but as scriptural counsel so it's a
rather
alarming movement because you can't
reason
with people who are working from
religion rather than logic and that's
not to say that religion
is idiocy in itself but a part of
religion
is that you sequester a part of your
brain away from
logic that goes from a to b to c you
have to suspend your disbelief
and the new wokeness wokeness that's
mean electivism as i'm calling it
is religious in that way and the people
in question can't be reached
and that's scary given how much power
they're beginning to amass
yeah well let's talk about that power um
you know what what is the power
you know critics of of anti-anti-racism
or anti-wokeness um you know we'll say
you know so
a couple of people lose their jobs um
you know rightly or wrongly or the
or they were racist you know uh uh
donald mcneil at the new york times an
old reporter who used the n-word
you know trying to clarify a statement
on a
class trip at peru for high school
students so it's already i'm like wow
this is taking place in a philip k
dick universe in an alternate reality
but you know he got cashiered for that
but
you know what he deserved to go and it's
not you know is that too
high a price to pay for a kind of
cleansing mural
moral purity you know what what are the
consequences of this kind of electivism
yeah the problem is that um it's not
just a few things
that's what a lot of people were saying
say in july august but it's been a while
these don mcneill stories are now
legion and the idea that he deserved to
lose this job
is not something that a critical mass of
people would agree with
it's the the elect who think that he
should lose his job
and what's going on is that the elect
get their way because we're all so
deeply afraid of being called racist
it's a reign of terror the reason that a
person can get fired
for some minor transgression like that
that nobody would ever have blinked at
or would have given him a smack on the
hand about just 10 minutes ago is
because nobody wants to be called a
racist on social media by these people
if there was no twitter there'd be no
elect part of this is technology
you don't want to be called elect on you
don't want to be called racist on
twitter
it used to be that maybe they would call
you a racist in a letter to the editor
but that didn't have the power that
twitter has and so the problem
is that this fear means that people lose
their jobs
for no moral reason it means that
educational institutions are being
turned upside down
into these anti-racism academies that
don't give people a real education
and excommunicate anybody who questions
it that's a serious problem right there
so some people will say
does this really matter a few reporters
lose their job whatever
some schools are changing that's not a
question that anybody concerned with the
heart of a society
would ask yes this is a this is a real
problem it's vastly
transforming our whole intellectual
moral and even artistic culture
and what bothers me so much about it is
that it's mendacious
it's all about fear it's not that these
people are convincing
most of society of these very narrow
extremist and self-indulgent views that
this hyper wokism has it's that
everybody's just afraid of them
and i think it's time that we stop being
so afraid who is driving this and
you know as with most uh kind of vague
social forces it's not you know there
isn't
somebody cracking the whip uh you know
in the rider's seat or something in the
driver's seat but
it you know who who is driving this is
it
a series of black elites is it white
elites is it some mix at one point you
uh
invoke at your sub stack the phrase
and i'm going to butcher it because i
cannot pronounce words very well but ken
d'angelo
angelonianism which is a portmanteau
of uh uh ibrahim kendi and robin
d'angelo
a black you know a a black scholar and a
white scholar
um you know what who who's who's who's
doing this
is it white elites is it black elites is
it just elites
what's going on it's it's them and so
part of the idea of candy angelonianism
is that it is that white person and that
black person
i hate to say this but the elect starts
with black people
it's a way of thinking about race that
acquired a certain hold on especially
academics
some artists and a lot of media people
after about 1966
this is when segregation like outright
obvious bigotry and you know and
um and disfranchisement that's over
and so you have to have a whole new kind
of conversation about what the problems
are and frankly it's then
that a certain kind of black person
devotes themselves to exaggerating
pretending that nothing really changed
pretending that black people are more
powerless than they are
that used to be a type and if you were
white who's
in an early who's who's an early
incarnation that starts with
stokely carmichael that starts with the
people yelling black power and not
really being quite sure what it even
meant
and a lot of people look back on that
era and i think partly because of the
fashions
and partly because the music was good
they think that that was somehow
significant that that was special but
you have to ask
what has black radicalism done
to help black america overall other
than be kind of a fashion statement
other than
lend some inspiring speeches you know
huey newton was very interesting
stokely carmichael was very interesting
amiri baraka was very interesting
but black america's victories have been
in spite
of them not because of anything that
they did nevertheless you had that kind
of person
and what this means is that the ibram
candy type has been with us for about 50
years but
it used to be that he was somebody who
you know got a doctorate from somewhere
and wrote some books and there you went
but
now we have the deangelo type and she's
a she's
not as young as a lot of the whites who
are doing this electness among white
people
tilts young although they're people who
are her age and older who have always
thought this way
who now have an influence that they
didn't have before and so white
fragility
a year ago i'd heard of it i wasn't
going to read it and i don't think i was
alone
in that that changed immediately because
of this racial reckoning
and so it's a it's a collaboration
unwittingly
between a certain kind of black radical
who i
with all do understanding think had
more to do with with posturing
than actually creating change in america
as we know it that's not they didn't do
it on purpose but
i don't see them as as important as some
historians do but
then you have a certain kind of white
fellow traveler that
cocktail it's another one of these
cocktails that is what's driving all of
this
whites who have founded their sense of
purpose on showing that they're not
racist and teaching other people not to
and black people who because it can be
hard to find your comfort zone and to
have a sense of purpose
for any human being is a kind of black
person who lives to paint
white people as the enemy because
therefore you are a noble victim the
noble victim complex that's homo sapiens
those together when you have black
people with that problem and white
people with their problem
is the elect and boy can that be
powerful because
those people like to call other people
racists and once there's social media
that can be really really scary unless
you're somebody
who has the disease of not minding being
despised that's not most people
how so how do you know you say it is um
you know kind of time to push back on
all of this and to
you know to argue with it and can uh
confront it or engage it
what what's to be done what are the ways
best ways to do that
well the truth is and you know nick i'm
working on
having a more comprehensive answer to
that because all of this happened so
very quickly
and we're all leading lives and i want
to be able to give council that
ordinary people who need to keep their
jobs
can can follow but the truth is we have
to understand that you cannot reason
with people like this and it's
very rare that you teach somebody out of
their religion and this is a religion
and so to try to talk these people down
doesn't work all they know is that
you're a racist and that's all you're
going to get
so the idea is not to try to have a
dialogue with them about these sorts of
issues you have to just shut down
but i think that we simply need to start
telling people like this no
and and the question is not how do you
stop them from calling you a racist on
social media you don't
that's what they're going to do and it's
time to start letting them do it
and going on about our business and you
know having our fellows around us having
our friends around us
and just making these sorts of people
realize that screaming that you were a
racist isn't going to get them what they
want
they've learned that that strategy works
and so they're going to keep using it
and
they're never going to consider that it
might not be the most humane or even
constructive way of doing things but
we're these are human beings and all of
us have that element
there's a lord of the flies element in
these people although they would never
recognize it in themselves
and so we need to start telling them no
and
i am working on how to get people to
actually consider
doing that because i i get at least
three emails a day from people who are
scared to death of the elect
and understand that these demands don't
make any sense and are destructive
but they need to keep their jobs or they
don't want to get screamed at they have
children
etc nevertheless something needs to be
done because these people will not stop
and they're not open to reason i just
think my analogy is um
with sharks i'm told i don't know this
is true but i'm told that
you can pop a shark on the nose i do not
mean violence against these people in
any way but
with these sorts of people i think if
you just said no i'm not a racist
and i don't care whether you put it on
twitter or not and i'm going to keep
doing what i'm doing
and keep looking them in the eye and
don't apologize if you do that enough
with these people they'll back down
but it has to be enough people doing it
that a subconscious group awareness
emerges among people like this that just
yelling dirty names is not going to
change the world the way they're hoping
do you feel there you know there is an
objective way or an empirical way you
were saying
you can't reason with certain people
which you know i think is true but
what are what are the factors that you
point to to say you know what
black america uh which is uh ridiculous
abstraction to begin with but
is actually doing better than it was 50
years ago or 30 years ago
um one of the curious facts of the past
year or so or since yeah i mean it's
basically a year since uh george floyd
um we we have been um every
every interaction that has gone violent
between cops and blacks has been
shown on you know network news or you
know and cable news and everything ad
nauseam
um yet the larger numbers don't seem to
have changed very much over the past
decade or even 15 years of the number of
police
killings of blacks unarmed blacks or
armed blacks
you know or white you know unarmed
whites you know armed whites etc
what what are the things that you point
to to make a case for those who are
looking for
you know some kind of data to suggest
you know what things are actually better
than
the way that we talk about them well you
know i think one thing that's
very important is to talk about just the
whole
police issue in general as you just did
because one of the main well
the driving factor in the idea that it
remains a tragedy to be black in the
united states is the relationship
between the cops
and particularly young black men and i
don't want to sound like one of these
people who's always railing at the
mainstream media for having sinister
agendas but we are
really really misled by the mainstream
media's obsession
with showing the deaths of young black
men while pretending that the same
things don't happen to young white men
too so it's at the point where i
personally see one of these horrible
things in the news happening to a black
man
and i think to myself i wonder how many
white men that happened to over the past
five years
and every single time it turns out that
that's the case it's just that those
cases didn't
make national news and that includes
george floyd there's been a
white boy named tony timpa was killed
that exact same way
a few years before him and so there's
that
talking about the cops but also there's
a very handy
kind of um mental picture that you might
want to give people
if you took a george wallace or if you
took one of these
dixiecrats from back in the day and you
reanimated them now
and had them you know watch a laptop i
want to say watch tv but i'm not sure
what that is today watch a laptop you
know for a couple of days drive around
that kind of person would have to pull
over and wretch
on the side of the highway seeing how
deeply black people and blackness
have permeated all levels of this
society strom
thurmond would be nauseated at the
america that we have achieved today even
since his death
how much blacker of the united states
has gotten and that matters
that very much matters and nobody could
possibly deny it
anybody who says that all of the civil
rights victories were basically negated
because of what happened to george floyd
one are not thinking about the fact that
that same thing happens
to white people as well and we simply
don't hear about it and also
that the country has come a very very
long way and you know it's one of those
things where
i am you know i'm 55 so i don't feel old
yet
but i know that 55 isn't young i worry
sometimes this is going to be a little
bit
you know get off my lawn but you have to
you have to say what you feel they're
people who are too young to understand
what it used to be like
and i wasn't alive when it was really
like what it was like but
i remember the 80s i remember how openly
racism could be expressed by some white
people
as late as the 80s i remember not
getting jobs
openly in the summer because i was black
and that's it i remember two cases like
that where i could tell that's what it
was and then asked later
somebody who knew and that's what it was
and yet yet the 80s compared to the 60s
was like the second reel of the wizard
of oz even then there had been immense
progress
but still the way it is now the the
browning of the culture
the very idea that everybody in the
country is listening to young black men
bragging as their favorite music and
loving the music
as poetry and loving it the way people
used to love walt whitman and edna st
vincent malay
and that's not superficial i mean
hip-hop is a religion too that's another
creed
that being a religion that crosses races
these are
unprecedented things and yet you have a
certain kind of person who wants to tell
you that nothing significant has really
changed since 1950
except manners and that what shows that
is george floyd
no that's highly childish reasoning
and unfortunately the elect have such
beautiful big words to express these
things that
it often sounds like they're saying
something more sophisticated than they
are
what uh what do you think undergirds
what what drives progress of the sort
you're talking about because it's it's
you know it's clearly happened
um but you know why why did it happen
and can we identify that and thus
either speed it up or make sure that it
doesn't get blocked or detoured
we convinced the country that racism was
a bad thing
a lot of very hard work was done in
congress
we tend to remember the people who did
it for things like marches and speeches
but
you know martin luther king and his
comrades worked very closely with people
in power to make
change happen i think we need to start
thinking about that now we think of it
as activism
to chase people out of their jobs for
not using the n-word the right way
that's not something that i think king
would have quite understood
there was that and then there was a
social revolution in the 1960s that i
don't think we fully understand yet
where a significant number of people
learn to understand that being a bigot
is wrong
i think sometimes people lack a little
historical imagination go to a cocktail
party
in your mind in 1964 if you watched mad
men
look at those people how would they have
felt about how you're supposed to feel
about a black person they would have
been all but unreachable
something changed very quickly and
that is a wonderful thing too and then
black people were able to do
what we were capable of once segregation
was no longer in the way
once people didn't openly hate us just
by seeing our faces as often as they had
we got to do what we can do now there
are still some obstacles
there is an inner city problem as we
used to call it the drug wars that was a
problem
the things that we need to get over but
the idea that america is
all about despising black people and
murdering our black bodies that's
fantasy
that's something from a comic book and
yet there are great many brilliant
people who are determined to make us
think that we're supposed to base our
whole lives
on this cartoon vision designed for
self-indulgence of both white and black
people
instead of actually creating change on
the ground
the way the people who made a life like
mine possible did
i think we're dishonoring the ancestors
at this point well uh we're going to
leave it there
i've been talking with john mcwhorter a
linguist at columbia university and the
author most recently of nasty words
english nine nasty words excuse me
english in the gutter then now and
forever
john just as a final point what is your
favorite curse word
when you are mad at your children and
wish to admonish them
uh what what what's your go-to uh
expletive i'm i'm big on [ __ ]
um i don't hurl it at my children but
they know the word very much from me
when something happens it's [ __ ] and i
like [ __ ]
i like to use that word in various ways
if something bad happens what i often
say is
mother that's what i often say and so
yeah i i like [ __ ] there's a
final chapter on [ __ ] in nine
nasty words because for me
i wanted that at the end because it's
kind of like a nice little nice little
post-prandial
kind of liqueur so i guess it's
[ __ ] that's my favorite all
right we're gonna leave it there
john mcwhorter thanks for talking to
reese thank you nick